make no mistake mowgli legend of the
jungle may be based on the Jungle Book
but it's definitely not for children
when Andy Serkis announced his plans
that direct a live-action adaptation of
The Jungle Book no one batted an eyelash
Disney's 1967 animated original was an
instant classic with wholesome elements
the viewers of all ages could enjoy
folded into a story of self-discovery
wouldn't circuses adaptation be just as
delightful unfortunately things panned
out poorly for mowgli not only that it
bombed with critics when it launched in
a limited theatrical run at the end of
november it also went over terribly with
a certain subset of its audience when it
hit Netflix on December 7th 2018 parents
discovered that not to unexpectedly
given the film's pg-13 rating Mowgli is
riddled with violence against humans and
animals soaked with bloodshed and
features a horrifying death that is
continually referenced throughout the
narrative those parents and guardians
have come forward to let others know
that Mowgli is quote traumatizing and
that they shouldn't let their kids watch
a second of it one of you I wrote on
Twitter in parts hashtag Mowgli what the
that twist is some sadistic I mean kids
would be traumatized another tweeted
dang of this hashtag Mowgli adaptation
on Netflix it's not really a kids movie
it's got some harsh scenes one parent
alerted others of a particular scenes
potentially psychologically damaging
effects saying there is a scene in
hashtag Mowgli that will absolutely scar
and shock young kids parents be warned
this version is incredible but very dark
plenty more on social media have won
that Mowgli is not for kids
and will take you by surprise with how
dark it is and that if they were a child
watching Mowgli they would be forever
haunted by a certain characters creepy
eyes it seems that many parents likely
run down and chasing after their
children all day or clocking in eight
hours at the office that they figured
that Mowgli would be appropriate for the
whole family and immediately press play
on Netflix without second thoughts
sadly they unknowingly bits are far more
than they all that kiddos could show
while parents up and warning are those
to steer clear of Mowgli when their kids
are around now that the film is on
Netflix
critics were doing exactly
that when the film was still in theaters
a review on decider warns the action
scenes where Mowgli is in danger are
legitimately scary and probably
traumatic for very little kids so buyer
beware definitely think it over before
traumatizing your kids are there unless
you're a giant Jungle Book aficionado
and crave complete ISM you can skip it
the independent called it quote
relentlessly discordantly bleak not
quite a kid's film not quite an adult
Swan just two years ago Jon Favreau
released his Walt Disney Pictures
produced Jungle Book to critical acclaim
and the men's box-office success
relax kid no need to get worked up ok
this is a cave
it's my cave a pic scored an Academy
Award for Best Visual Effects smashed
records to become one of the top
grossing movies of 2016 and Rotten
Tomatoes summarizes the film's reviews
with Jungle Book is a rare remake that
actually improves upon its predecessors
all while setting a new standard for CGI
it would be impossible for circus to
replicate the magic of Favreau's film
but it was hardly a stretch to assume
that Mowgli could pick up praise from
members of the media and make a Disney
fans young and old smile sadly while a
handful of reviewers have respected
circuses grim approach to the Jungle
Book
the general consensus is that the
director went off the deep end and made
things entirely too dark his desire to
create something different with Mowgli
was ultimately and unfortunately his
undoing
[Music]